you have an impact on adults in the
world who are who are trying to find out
what's going out the news but children
as well there's this great clip that's
been going around of an NBC reporter
interviewing a boy and let's show the
clip and then I'm just curious when you
when you happen to come across this take
a look what's on your mind wondering ha
I didn't really see one TV that much but
Lester Holt Lester Holt I usually see
him more on the news and you
[Laughter]
if you had a mic you would have dropped
it reporters like you're not Lester Holt
I'm out of here
so I'm sitting at my desk last week and
you know I get one of those you know
chain type emails and says you gotta
watch this you gotta watch this and I
was like okay let me watch it I was
having a lousy day and I click that on
and watch the whole thing and big grin
on my face what his name is Jaden and he
wanted to be interviewed by a lesser
role you got as you've got to make that
happen I will tell you that we are in
contact with Jaden and stay tuned
[Applause]
you